véronique jacquier journaliste auteur de
ce livre l'homme qui ne voulait pas être
président aux éditions l'artilleur bon
soit vers une exacte et merci d'être en
direct sur rt france donc réquisitions
deux ans ferme pour françois fillon
quel est votre but sur sa ligne ne
laissera pas a priori revendant ses rien
évidemment mais deux ans apparaît plutôt
clément est ce que c'est un réquisitoire
sévère alors dans leurs plaidoiries les
et enfin dans leur réquisitoire plus tôt
les procureurs ont été sévères dans la
forme dans le langage employé ils n'ont
pas loupé françois fillon sens propre du
terme
maintenant si on regarde effectivement
le fond deux ans ferme
c'est l'assurance quelque part qu'on l'a
quand même ménagé parce qu'ils ne les
fera pas c'est un peu le syndrome
cahuzacois première instance il avait
été lui-même traumatisés parce qu'il
avait dit pas la prison pas la prison et
puis en deuxième instance il avait eu
deux ans de prison ferme et ça s'est
terminé par le port d'un bracelet
électronique
donc françois fillon pourrait ne pas
faire de prison alors certes on va dire
que ça peut être une infamie comme à un
tel réquisitoire pour un ancien premier
ministre c'est le premier ancien premier
ministre à être jugé de la sorte mais
attention on reste sur un réquisitoire
et ce n'est pas encore un jugement le
jugement ce sera le 29 juin prochain
du sursis pour son épouse pénélope
fillon qui a semble-t-il beaucoup
souffert pendant ce procès ça avait
l'air très compliqué pour elle de se
trouver là et de répondre au juge c'est
l'une des images qu'on retiendra de ce
procès oui tout à fait elle a beaucoup
souffert
son avocat maître cornut gentille l'a
dit encore aujourd'hui il a aussi
insisté sur le fait que pour elle depuis
trois ans et est un chemin de croix que
c'était une femme qui était vraiment
recroquevillée sur elle c'est évidemment
extrêmement violent mais les procureurs
a d'ailleurs ne l'ont pas nier
nous ont dit nous avons de la peine pour
vous madame fillon quelque part c'est
toujours françois fillon qui était visé
à travers les attaques ou à travers les
questions qu'on pose et à son épouse
puisque les procureurs ont dit que pour
eux c'est est une victime consentante
ce en quoi dans la défense aujourd'hui
les avocats de françois fillon on dit
mais non ce n'était pas une victime
consentante
c'est elle épouse d'un député qui de par
cette fonction était au contraire une
collaboratrice avec un statut
particulier donc un statut qui pouvaient
prétendre à être comparé à celui d'un
assistant parlementaire
en fait ce qu'on comprend à travers les
mots et en filigrane c'est que ce que
les avocats ont voulu démontrer
aujourd'hui c'est que il y avait
peut-être pas debout traces de son
travail il n'y avait pas le il n'y avait
pas grand chose de très consistant mais
on pouvait pas dire qu'elle n'avait pas
travaillé on pouvait peut-être subodorer
qu'elle avait été trop payés mais madame
fignon dans la sarthe dans leur
circonscription s'était pas n'importe
qui elle a été en tout cas mise
plusieurs fois en difficulté 1
quant à la durée projetée mise en
difficulté parce que malheureusement
elle n'a pas été en capacité de bien se
défendre parce qu'elle est extrêmement
timide et que je pense quand même
qu'elle était sacrément secoués comme ça
de comparaître devant le pnf le parquet
national financiers s'étaient pas rien
c'est effectivement une épreuve tout le
monde l'a reconnu y compris les membres
du pnf et elle a eu effectivement du mal
à expliciter quelles étaient ses
missions pendant tant d'années
alors les avocats sont venus à la
rescousse aujourd'hui lors de la défense
en disant mais vous vous rendez compte
vous demandez à à pénélope fillon
d'expliquer ce qu'est la fée il ya 30
ans il ya 25 ans c'est très très
compliqué bon c'est vrai après le
problème c'est que les avocats
aujourd'hui de françois fillon et de
pénélope n'ont pas été en mesure
d'apporter beaucoup de consistance sur
le travail qui a été fait alors
justement les avocats qui ont plaidé un
procès à charge
comment vous apprécié ces propos vous
qui avez justement suivi toute cette
affaire toute cette campagne incroyable
de la liste de françois fillon voulait
dire oui on est criminel
et ils ont éprouvé d'un procès sur les
avocats de françois fillon qui ont
également demandé au tribunal de prendre
en compte la séparation des pouvoirs
c'est une critique qui revient très
souvent un manque de neutralité de ce
parc et financiers créés sous françois
hollande on le rappelle ça pose question
effectivement ça interroge oui ils ont
aussi évoqué le les fuites pendant la
campagne présidentielle avec la levée
permanente du secret de l'instruction
ça c'est un fait cette campagne
présidentielle elle a été marquée par la
levée du secret de l'instruction des que
dès qu' il y avait eu une audience même
des enfants de françois fillon
plus tard c'était dans la bafin même pas
même pas dix jours plus tard c'était
dans la presse avec des détails
circonstancié donc évidemment cela
interroge donc oui il dise que
l'instruction a été menée à charge au
nom de la séparation des pouvoirs le pnf
n'a pas menti là dessus les procureurs
ont dit hier mais il n'y a pas de
séparation des pouvoirs
l'assemblée nationale n'est pas un
sanctuaire et les hommes politiques sont
des hommes comme les autres pourquoi y
aurait-il un traitement différent
pourquoi est-ce qu'on pourrait pas les
nôtres mais de notre nez finalement dans
les agissements des politiques puisqu'il
se servent de l'argent public et le pen
finalement assume de dire il ya un avant
et un après le parquet financier
maintenant le pnf a aussi dit hier
puisque on l'a un peu passé sous silence
mais on a traité que ma main de la
célérité de la justice pendant cette
campagne présidentielle et le procureur
a dit oui mais on n'aurait pas agi on
aurait été critiqués on aurait agi plus
tard en aurait été critiqué
on a agi en moins de 24 heures on est
critiqués bon on assume
effectivement la justice a agi très vite
en tout cas à l'époque lé procès c'est
que maintenant mes mails à la justice
s'est saisie avec une sévérité qui qui
n'est pas dont elle n'est pas toujours
coutumière
c'est une justice à deux vitesses en
tout cas les détracteurs peuvent le gel
a jugé ainsi ben oui j'en parle
d'ailleurs dans mon ouvrage est ce qu'il
ya eu une justice particulière pour
françois fillon
oui il ya une justice particulière pour
françois fillon il suffit de regarder
les faits le parquet national financiers
ne s'est toujours pas saisie de l
enquête sur les assistants
parlementaires européens du modem
or il a quand même agi très vite pour se
saisir de l'enquète sur les assistants
parlementaires européens du
rassemblement national à quelque chose
près c'est pas le nombre c'est pas le
même nombre de gens incriminés mais
c'est exactement la même affaire donc
pourquoi d'un côté on laisse tranquille
françois bayrou et le modem pourquoi
d'un autre côté on ne laisse pas
tranquille marine le pen son père jean
marie le pen et le rassemblement
national parce que même le parti mise en
examen là on voit clairement deux poids
et deux mesures
idem pour richard ferrand le président
de l'assemblée nationale où le parquet
national financier a fini par se saisir
de l'enquète parce que l'association
anticor est revenu à la charge
et puis enfin dernier point qui est
tombé maintenant dans les limbes
c'est quand même le cas de bruno le roux
qui quand même pendant la campagne
présidentielle a été une victime
collatérale de la sphère fillon parce
que lui aussi avait employé deux de ses
filles mineures à l'assemblée nationale
ça a été reconnue ou subodorer comme des
emplois fictifs françois hollande lui a
dit tu prend la porte
on a eu donc droit à un éphémère
ministre de l'intérieur et depuis plus
rien concernant bruno le roux plus rien
on ne sait même pas où ils enquêtent en
est et le pnf ne s'est pas saisie de la
faire bruno l'euro alors les
conséquences évidemment inutile de le
rappeler ont été immenses avec cette
saisie
du bnf à l'époque puisque françois
fillon a donc évidemment perdu cette
course à la présidentielle
est ce que le pnf aujourd'hui peut juger
de manière finalement totalement
impartial avec une neutralité parfaite
sous peine même de se déjuger
quand on voit les conséquences que ça a
eu voilà ça a dépassé françois fillon
bien évidemment un
alors c'est une question pertinente
quand j'ai enquêté justement pour mon
ouvrage j'ai interrogé des magistrats
qui m'ont dit mais si froch si le pnf à
dégainer aussi vite dans la pendant la
campagne présidentielle c'est parce que
françois fillon était un présidentiable
donc ils sont enfin il se permettait
donc de le mettre en fragilité et
quelque part ensuite la presse ont
évidemment en donnant les informations
on voit comment ça se passe maintenant
il a été jugé par l'opinion publique
avant d'être jugé par la justice de
toute façon donc c'est un peu le saas
est déjà le drame de notre époque
maintenant est ce que le pen est
finalement est capable de rendre une
justice d'une manière équitable et d'une
manière juste
oui franchement on peut le souhaiter moi
j'ai bien écouté le réquisitoire sur le
factuel
j'ai trouvé qu'ils étaient extrêmement
précis et extrêmement juste parce que
finalement le pnf dit il y a un avant
park parc national financier il ya un
après si françois fillon le juge
sévèrement c'est parce qu'il à laver
plus blanc que blanc pendant quarante
ans de vie politique
et ça ça ne passe plus rappelons quand
même que il y a eu un député qui a été
condamnée par le pnf desjardins c'est le
seul exemple qu'on a pour faire le la
comparaison avec françois fillon
c'est le député alain marsaud qui pour
l'emploi de sa fille pendant quatre ans
a écopé d'un an de prison avec sursis et
300 mille euros d'amendé
votre livre à un nom évocateur l'homme
qui ne voulait pas être président ça
veut dire quoi c'est que finalement
françois fillon une fois empêtré dans
ses affaires ne s'est pas défendu aussi
bien qu'il aurait peut-être pu le faire
voilà en fait je démontre que
il a été sévèrement attaquée mais qu'il
s'est mal défendu sans doute parce qu'au
fond de lui il n'avait pas la niaque
suffisante pour tout mettre dans l'arène
tout jeter dans l'arène peut-être
prendre un avocat plus pugnacais plus
politique le pnf on l'a dit ils sont
instituées par françois hollande et il
avait mis à l'époque à sa tête yens
houlette qui était donc réputé plutôt de
gauche est bon quand on est candidat à
la présidentielle qu'on voit les mailles
de la justice se resserrait ne pas se
dire attention je n'ai pas forcément à
faire à des gens qui vont me lâcher or
françois fillon a été naïf sur ce plan
là il a cru dès le début de la campagne
quand le canard enchaîné s'est jeté sur
lui que on n'allait plus finalement le
laisser tranquille s'il apporte quelques
documents il a eu aussi cette naïveté de
dire si je suis mise en examen
évidemment j'abandonnerai la campagne
mais oui avec le pnf françois fillon on
aurait dû anticiper qu'il allait de mise
en examen qu'on n'allait pas le laisser
tranquille
ils voulaient laver son honneur françois
fillon avec ce procès son image elle en
sort
comment selon vous encore plus écornée
au bain il reste des fillonniste dans le
cercle de cette politique disparu et les
fillonnistes continuerons à dire que
françois fillon a été massacrée et qu'on
a loupé un bon président pour faire la
part des choses il faut quand même
regarder que dans l'entourage de
françois fillon parmi les politiques il
n'y a quand même pas grand monde pour le
défendre
il n'y a pas grand monde on l'a vu
d'ailleurs un les fillonnistes restent
discrets ils sont passés à autre chose
ils ont tourné la page
bon pour être un petit peu triviale
personne ne veut tirer sur une ambulance
il en restera beaucoup de regrets à
droite pour un homme qui aurait pu être
un homme d'état il sans doute un bon
président merci en tout cas à véronique
jacquier journaliste auteur de l'homme
qui ne voulait pas être présidence
d'édition l'artilleur merci d'avoir été
avec nous